Well, how was a Firefox born?
How's Mozilla born? Is there a sh.
There's a long story there too. So Netscape got acquired by AOL, which has,
as I say, was a reasonable happy ending for a lot of people because Netscape,
otherwise was going to go out of business because Microsoft was just killing its
market. There was no way to charge for browser.
Windows came with I E I four was pretty good and let's get four.
It wasn't that good. It took a while to get better. Um,
but then this game executive said, let's do an open source escape pod,
you know, and like in star Wars, a new hope,
the gunner won't shoot it cause there's no lifeforms on, right.
It's not a threat. Uh,
and so when we did Mozilla in 1998 and it looked like it was going
to, you know, initially just give the world of open-source browser,
but it's really hard to get people to work on this sort of hairball had been
hacked up over by that point for years. Uh,
it also couldn't have the crypto module for secure sockets so-called or now
transport layer security. That was an electronic munition.
We're not allowed to release that in the full 1000,
24 bit keen strength. And, um, yet people,
one of whom I happened to meet previously at SGI,
when I went on a sales support engineering trip, uh, Tim Hudson in Brisbane,
Australia, and, um, Eric,
a young did what became open SSL.
It was called SSL EA why after Eric's initials and Tim and Eric
took their openness of sell outside of the purview of the NSA and the
department of commerce. And they stuck it into Muzzillo's code.
And that was perhaps the best hack that was done in the first few months after
we opened sourced the browser, we had other problems,
the politics inside Netscape were driven by these acquisitions.
So the one acquisition that kind of messed up Netscape for also wanted to keep
doing a proprietary mail and group ware program,
not Jamie is the one skis mail program that was in Netscape two and three,
and they held it back. We're open source. We didn't have a mail program.
It was just a browser. We didn't know what Ella will do to us.
It turns out they didn't interfere with us for a long time,
but Netscape wasn't the best steward of Mozilla.
We were operating Mozilla as a pirate ship without a legal entity.
So most of us worked for Netscape under a separate organization. And,
um, initially, uh, the first engineering manager,
Tom Payclin of Netscape was the muzzle founding manager, but he,
he left pretty quickly and he left me as the acting manager,
which is more like method acting in my case. And, um, and I did,
that was my first management stint, but then, um,
someone who'd written the licenses, Mitchell Baker,
she was a lawyer and Netscape. She was involved in the open source license, uh,
decision making and the actual writing and construction of those licenses.
That was Mitchell's job Netscape, public license,
and the truly open Mozilla public license.
And there were two because Netscape needed because of some encumbered code
needed some special, but that went away over time.
Mitchell was almost interested in Mozilla and she came back from maternity leave
and she said, Oh, I'll be the manager if you want. And, and Jamie and I said,
sure. And then Jamie, quit. He quit after a year. He said, this didn't work.
I'm sorry. You know, he acted like it was a total failure because most of all,
it didn't restart the browser market, but there's no way it could have. Right.
And Netscape was still shipping variants and Netscape four,
which was based on the old code Mozilla was trying to react to the code to make
Greenfield for developers. So it was one of my big goals.
It wasn't a technical goal so much as again, a social goal.
People wanted a more standard spaced browser.
They wanted less of a hairball that hacked on by X grad students starting four
years prior. So we said, we're going to make a modular code base.
We're going to use a variant or an open source version of Microsoft component.
Object model has referenced counting and standardized the tables,
virtual calls in C plus plus. And we're going to use a JavaScript.
We're going to have a bridge between those two.
So you can script those components, just like Java components. Um,
we're going to make a portable front end with a markup language for the user
user interface, not tables, not HTML, but custom, you know,
menus and drop-downs and toolbars. And,
and that was called Zul XML, user interface language,
and some real talent on the Netscape side deliver that Dave Hyatt, who, uh,
was instrumental in Zola, Chris Waterson, um, Joe Hewitt, um,
Blake Ross, and th uh, Blake was an intern.
He was like a high school aged intern in that school.
And at some point we were innovating rapidly in the Muslim world.
And Netscape was still caught up in this management mess from these acquisitions
and it wasn't delivering.
And every year they were wondering if AOL was going to come and start beheading
the executives, because it didn't do anything useful.
And there was a thought you should take the Netscape browser engine and put it
in the windows AOL client,
which was the dialogue client that all the increasingly aging users of all or
using never happened. It would have been a bit too big to change.
So it wasn't clear why LL bought Netscape. Let's just say they left it alone,
but Netscape didn't leave Mozilla alone. And so, um,
in 2001, uh, Mitchell called me up and said, I'm no longer employed.
And I was like, what? You quit? No, no, this wasn't my choice.
And there was a layoff, uh,
which maybe accidentally or on purpose got rid of Mitchell.
But the funny thing was we had an open source project.
We had a lot of the engineers on staff on our side, and we had, um,
people we'd hired through them as little community were top-notch,
they'd written, you know, they came in high quality,
they knew the code and they actually were better than the average or median hire
of Netscape.
And so the funny thing was the executive who thought they'd
gotten rid of Mitchell and the layoff on the next week's community call around
muzzle and what to do there's Mitchell.
And so this show, you can kind of transcend.
Your, uh, you know, boundaries of corporate open source.
If you get a project that has enough loyalty, even among the paid staff.
Cause we had outside people contributing with people at red hat and few other
places, but the majority of the hackers were employed by Netscape.
But a lot of them at that point had had come from the community and others got
the community and wanted to work with it.
And it was really the weakest engineers and Netscape didn't like Mozilla.
And didn't like the crucible of competing with the better, uh,
programmers. So that's, the project is good enough. It will arise.
The Phoenix will rise out of the that's exactly right. And so we had this,
this Mozilla code base that was getting better. In fact,
I think at some point in 2002,
when we declared w most a little one O w I engineer roadmap that
successively through similar sort of six week, five week releases,
like we all do with browser releases nowadays Chrome does and Firefox, um,
Braves, the three weeks we, we, we got to a point where we said, you know what?
It doesn't suck. This is like the one Oh that you want to release,
because if you hold it back any longer to Polish, it you're denying others.
The ability to use it. It's like pro engineer,
the mechanical CAD tool embedded the code. They embedded the layout engine.
Um, and Mozilla one, Oh, was like a Netscape communication suite.
We had at that point, gotten mail people to reintegrate, mail and news.
And we had an editor for HTML and it felt like a nineties sweet,
sweet, where, um,
and it felt kind of bloated and the people who were taking that Mozilla open
source and then adding Netscape flavor to it calling the shots, right.
And they were also under ALS thumb a little bit. And that they said, well,
we should probably put the AOL instant messenger chicklet on the toolbar.
And we should put the ICQ, the other messages that AOL had acquired,
we should put the ICQ button on the toolbar.
And pretty soon Netscape looked like a bit of a NASCAR badged
Mazola, and that also made Mozilla more popular. And, and yet, um, they,
they had, you know, contrived to, um,
fire or lay off the leader. And, and,
and we carried on with an open-source structure where Maslow was still in,
you know, Mitchell was calling sort of management or project level shots.
And I was calling technical shots. And, um, we,
we had a popular suite, but we thought,
why not make it just a browser because it'll be simpler, it'll do one job well,
and even then we can strip it down by half having extensions.
So Dave Hyatt and Blake Ross,
the high school aged intern did the first version,
which was called most of the loss slash browser. It was very small group of us,
Ian Hixson, EISA thoughts, or me, and, uh,
Joe Hewitt and Hyatt and Blake and, and they, and high.
It was really the senior hacker. He'd done all these things like amazing, uh,
cross-platform menus through the user interface, markup language. Um,
and he knew how to do tab browsing and implemented it natively on Macalester at
the time in Camino, um, originally called Kymera he'd,
he'd written multiple flotations, which was a thing programmers should do.
It's like the VA team did for those missing years when the rest of the Chrome
team's like where's V8. Um, at that Dave's wife,
Rebecca told me a story about when they were at UIC.
They were also university of Illinois, uh, grad students. Um,
there was an assignment,
it was a programming assignment to do the end of the semester.
And Dave's friend was this, I'm going to go think,
and I'm going to design and I'm going to make this, you know,
platonic perfect form of the program.
And then I'm going to write it at the end when it's due and high,
it just went there and started hacking. He wrote one version,
you wrote a second version,
third version end of the semester comes around the friends, not two and two.
Well, it wasn't perfect. And it wasn't written,
I'm not sure if how that story ended, but for him,
but Dave's version was fifth iteration was great.
And so he'd done that with everything you need in a browser.
And this really showed well in Phoenix, what we called Phoenix,
and it had to rename two more times. Um, and you know, uh,
Blake went to Stanford, he became a Stanford student and couldn't work on it.
Um, Dave Hyatt went to Apple in 2001.
He was one of the founding Safari team members. Um.
Interesting. But he was still blogging.
About tabbed browsing. I think Apple, at some point said, sorry,
I have to have browsing. Yeah. But it was because of Hyatt high.
It was quite a feather in their cap that Don Melton at, uh,
who had been the engineering manager at, at, at, for Safari, from the beginning,
uh, had been in that scape also. And so this is the, a spore of talent and,
and yet high, it was still kind of writing blog posts about how to do tabs,
right. And at some point Apple said, don't, don't blog about that.
That's our proprietary tab technology. And it's like, no, it's not,
it was an opera and I've refined it. Um,
so we had to replace people and we had Ben Goodyear, uh,
New Zealand.
We hired it in this game and he stepped in to be the F Firefox lead.
And we also had this weird circumstance where AOL finally did notice that
Netscape was kind of a albatross that they bought it for no particular benefit.
And even then the AOL politics were also heinous sort of East coast politics.
I remember taking two trips there cause I was the principal engineer.
And so I was principal engineers got trotted out to do dog and pony shows in
Dulles, Virginia. And the, uh,
the upper management was very East coast and flavor.
And they were at that time merging with time Warner not go well.
So one of these years we went out there and we were all doing dog and pony
shows. And there were these characters that were sort of like marketing guys,
one of the most wearing a crevasse and their mom was named Reggie and they were,
they were, they were very, um,
you rather than non you, or they were like, what's, what's,
Stillman's metropolitan film. UHV um, urban Bush,
we, which was the, um, they were [inaudible], they, they were, um,
funny and they were kind of useless and kind of preppy. And then the next year we went back and I said, where's Reggie. And it's like, Oh,
Richie's not here anymore. Because
time Warner realized that the merger wasn't in their interest either, and then the sort of knives came out and this was these, these mergers really work, right.
It's, it's
very difficult. You get these giant companies and they think there's going to be synergy. That was the nineties late nineties
and watch ward
. And there wasn't synergy with AOL by Netscape. And there wasn't synergy with time Warner.
Does it AOL.
Ever really work? Was it ever really cool.
Like the same kind of fire and excitement that Firefox eventually created was
that ever there and AOL.
AOL was the right time to do a dial up service that got distribution
by basically leaflet, bombing, compact discs, right on the country.
And they beat out CompuServe and the other ones prodigy,
and then the web happened. And so you had almost like this, um,
isolated continent, like some of the evolutionary biologist, I follow them,
make fun of the, the, the funny large mammals, you know, uh,
marsupial mammals of, of Australia, how, how silly they are.
And so AOL is like Australia and,
and you saw it over time because they kept aging and they were using AOL to get
online. And they couldn't really use a web browser. And it became sort of a,
a valued cohort.
Cause they're still have relatively high socioeconomic status and they have
grandchildren, but it's going away. It's dying at some point.
The end of the arts that decade, and then to the decade, uh,
2010, plus that Firefox became this incredible.
I feel I'm Chrome came out, but I made September, 2008,
but Firefox was the sexy, cool thing.
That's represented a lot of the cutting edge technologies and all that kind of
stuff.
To it. It was amazing people rally.
And John Battelle did the first web two conference,
which eventually became huge and they split it. But that was in 2004.
It was right when Firefox was out, Craigslist was, it was a huge,
it was killing classified revenue for newspapers. But, um,
there was just this ferment people starting pedia along their email,
it was already done. And it was an impressive web mail.
There were others before like Hotmail,
but Gmail is really impressive from Google and Google maps.
People started seeing what could be done. They thought,
how can you drag the map around? And you know, how does that work?
And it was all JavaScript and images and, and, um.
Gmail was 2003, four.
I actually started quite early. It might've been 2002 or three,
but by the time we started dealing with Google with Firefox to get the search
deal, which was the main revenue source from Azula and still is, um,
2004 early Sergei. Brin's, uh, one of his trusted engineer guys,
Fred Schneider made contact with me and Mazola and we started talking and we
realized, um, search and browser need each other. And this is deeply true,
right? This is still true.
This is why a lot of the search engines have their own browsers.
Yeah. So in case people don't know the,
the main revenue source for the browser is the default search engine,
which is kind of incredible to think about that, uh, that,
that is a revenue source. It's a little bit sad.
Yeah.
It leads to this capture or kill effect where you have the search engine own its
own browser. And other browsers may struggle to get distribution.
We talked about earlier.
So where, and you said, uh, you've figured out that, uh,
Google is working on its own browser at some point that I'm six, 2006.
So would you say Firefox versus was internet Explorer part of the war here or
was the Firefox versus Chrome?
So Firefox didn't quite cause Microsoft to reconvene.
I E they did do [inaudible]
. And I remember being on a plane back from the standards meeting Josh senators
, meeting
from Seattle, from Redmond. And there was some Microsoft guy in front of me. It turns out my wife knew him from her past life before we married. And he was just this bearded big guy. And he was like,
well, you should have
just killed Firefox in the cradle. All we needed to do was add public blocking
in and tabs. And we could have made an internet kill
Firefox. And it's like, shoulda, coulda, woulda pal. And I was already behind them
hearing that. Um,
but they didn't, they were slow and they ice seven. Wasn't that great. And what
really got them started, I think was, um,
Chrome. And, you know, I talked to Larry Page in 2005, I think I said, you know, we're talking about the Firefox relationship, but he was also saying, what
about WebKit?
This was Apple's version of the old cage email engine from,
from Linux, the KT East side of Linux. Um,
those used in the conqueror browser also with case that Apple had forked and,
and in 2005 was when Apple's principles, including Dave Hyatt, Manchester,
Coby X, some of my friends who were still there said, we, we must stop patch,
bombing this poor Katie KML project.
We should make a proper Muslim like organization webkit.org.
Now it wasn't a separate nonprofit or anything. It was still Apple,
it was Apple controlled,
but they made their fork first-class and they made it be something that they all
worked in and lived in. And that was before Chrome.
And then Chrome Larry Page said, what about web? Can I say, yeah, it's nice.
I have friends who work on it. You might use that. If you do your own browser,
why don't you do your own browser? Don't worry about Firefox.
You should do your own browser.
You can have your own opinion of how it should work and sure enough, they did.
So by 2006, we knew they'd been working on it. Some of the,
some of my friends who'd been at Netscape did the original demo and the demo,
wasn't what you thought it didn't have.
The fast JavaScript you had that was still often Denmark in the farm, um,
did have tabs. It had tabs because all browsers had tabs disappoint and it had,
uh, this software fault isolation.
They mentioned it was through process isolation. So in theory,
each tab has its own operating system process.
And so the what's going to take your tab down. Well,
web kit has bugs that can crash it, but flash was still big.
Then all the restaurant sites remember and flash crashed a lot.
So the demo that I heard about my friends ex Netscape X there's,
a lot of people did inside Google was the sad tab.
They showed an early version of Chrome,
which is just this bare bones tab browser.
They loaded the site with a known flash phone and that suddenly flash crashes,
and everyone expected the whole browser to go down.
But instead you got this little sad face in the tab,
and then you could reload it. And there it is again. So this was, this was, uh,
an improvement. It was a real move for security.
It was based on a company they acquired called green border that had some really
big brains like old fart Ellingson, I think was involved in,
they had done some exotic, uh, security stuff,
but they ended up simplifying it to this process isolation. And, um,
it was good and Firefox didn't have it at the time.
So we were still struggling with, you know, uh, security, bugs. Um,
so we knew Chrome was coming, but it took two more years to come out.
And at the time we were still getting, you know,
the Google search revenue and we were still, um,
making Google the default engine and Firefox was still growing and Firefox grew,
I think until 2011, that was when it peaked. And as it started falling,
it was because of Chrome, Chrome hanging out in 2008.
And it was a comic book that leaked accidentally that showed some of the people
who worked on it, Lars Bach was in there. And so on,
it was kind of soft launch because they didn't market it heavily.
They didn't push distribution,
but Google had reason to worry about distribution because Microsoft was,
you know, doing a search engine beings since 2007. In fact,
when they came out with Bing,
Google was worried that Microsoft would just brute force switch the default
browser and everyone's internet Explorer or Firefox on windows to being
from Google and, uh, Microsoft wasn't I think,
ready to dare the antitrust cops that way, even though they'd gone to sleep.
And, uh, I don't think thing was ready either,
but just in case it happens Sundar Pichai who Rose very well based on
this work was sort of, uh, in charge of getting distribution deals.
And he got Google toolbar and Google desktop search distribution.
And remember those pieces of software, those were like desktop, uh, extensions,
toolbars,
or operating system extensions for doing desktop search search and your local
files kind of like a spotlight, right? Sadly die of doubt. They all died.
And there were some features that we still missed that didn't make it into
Chrome, but Sunday got OEMs to bundle those.
And then he got enough of those deals that by 2007 or eight, Google felt well,
if being Microsoft does the worst and tries to force Bing,
we can reach in and reset it with that point of presence. So that was, you know,
good for Sundar his career. And it was good for Google,
but it never came to pass that they had to defend. Microsoft was still,
you know, slow. And by the time they saw Chrome come out,
then they did what would have been INI. And then they said,
we're going to have a fast JavaScript engine to chakra chopper core. And, um,
they get, okay. They were another process,
isolated fast JavaScript browser tab browser.
So it sounds like there's a deep,
fundamental coupling of search engine and browser.
That's mixing this whole thing up and obviously Firefox doesn't have, uh,
a search engine. That's like, I mean, you're, you're,
you're partnering with one with somebody with a search engine. Yeah. With,
with Yahoo or with, uh, uh, with Google or something.
They tried Yahoo. That was unfortunately, because I think, um,
even though Marissa Mayer talked about it,
she never pulled it off and never restored the search, uh,
team that had been laid off. I believe Carol Bartz was running Yahoo.
And Carol said, I've got to get rid of one of three expensive things.
I'm going to get rid of search. And, um,
those researchers went to Google and Microsoft,
and there was no way to put Yahoo search back together.
So when Firefox tried switching all their users,
who'd stuck with a default from, to Yahoo, like mid December, 2014.
That's what just happened to my firebox. And others didn't notice right away,
but over time they did. And so over the next year,
the traffic just went away for Yahoo and,
and yet they were obliged. I understand it. I, I don't have inside knowledge,
but this is leaked out. And Danny Sullivan's written about it.
Search engine land. I think the deal was like fixed payments to Mozilla.
So Mozilla was getting a bunch of money for traffic that wasn't staying because
users were resetting their default and this shows how defaults are important,
but they have to be good enough that the user doesn't override them.
And you know,
a lot of the commercial value in popular apps is one of the default settings.
What is the default search?
But oftentimes there's sometimes just like you said, I mean,
if there's something compelling,
that's also can beat out the default like tab browsing and so on. Yes.